بعد اشهر قليله من قيام شركه اوبن ايلا
امريكيه باطلاق روبوت او برنامج للذكاء
الاصطناعي تحت اسم
المثير للجدل اعلنت شركه جوجل اطلاق روبوت
منافس يحمل اسم فارد هذا الروبوت يبدو
وكانه منافس قوي لبرنامج الذكاء الاصطناعي
اذ انه يعطي مفهوما جديدا للبحث عبر
الانترنت وذلك من خلال برامج لغويه غير
مسبوقه مع ذكاء اصطناعي شامل وقدره على
الابتكار واجمالا تختلف طريقه عمل بارد عن
تلك الخاصه بالروبوت اذ يعتمد الروبوت
الاخير على قاعده بيانات محدده لجمع
معلوماته وليس عبر شبكه الانترنت
ومن ثم سيكون بارد اشبه بمحرك بحث يتمتع
بذكاء اصطناعي قياسي ويستند بارد الى
برنامج حاسوبي صممته جوجل ويحمل اسم لامدا
ومع ان الذكاء الاصطناعيه منتشر منذ سنوات
فان اصدار روبوت في شهر نوفمبر تشرين
الثاني سلطت الضوء على ما يسمى بالذكاء
الاصطناعي القادري على صنع محتوى او نص او
رمز او صوره او صوت استنادا الى البيانات
المتاحه له وقد اعتبر اطلاق تشاد بمثابه
صدمه لجوجل الا انها انكبت على العمل
لابتكار اداه منافسه
ولكن ما هي الاسباب التي دفعت جوجل لاطلاق
هذا الروبوت الخاص بها الى وقت قريب كانت
جوجل تهيمن على قطاع البحث على شبكه
الانترنت على مدى عقدين من الزمن دون
منافس يذكر ففي كل ثانيه تعالج جوجل حوالي
100,000 عمليه بحث على شبكه الانترنت وذلك
بفضل خوارزمياتها الذكيه وهو مد لتوسيع
اعمالها لتشمل خدمات كثيره منها متصفح
كروم وبريد جيميل ونظام التشغيل اندرويد
وجوجل مابس وغيرها هذا الامر يجلب للشركه
مليارات الدولارات من الاعلانات لتصل
القيمه السوقيه لشركه الفابيت الى تريليون
وثلاثمائه مليار دولار ومع ظهور روبوت
تشارجي بدات جوجل تحث الخطى لولوجي قطاع
الذكاء الاصطناعي ليكون المحور الرئيسي في
عملها بحلول عام 2025